right reviewed the 3d as Super Smash
Brothers now we'll take it to the Wii U
spoiler alert
pretty sweet Super Smash Brothers on the
Wii U so Super Smash Brothers on the Wii
U is the newest Smash Brothers red there
was one for the 3ds as ones on the Wii U
there are a lot of the same game but
they do have differences differences
enough where you feel like the 3ds
version was the test run and all right
here's Wii U here's the powerhouse on
that I feel like you can springboard off
of my 3ds review and lands right into
this I feel like my 3ds game review can
be like a companion piece to this review
so you can get the whole spectrum of
what I'm talking about but for those of
you who don't know Super Smash Brothers
is a fighting game made by Nintendo
where nintendo brand nintendo games and
some that are not nintendo brand
nintendo games they fight or so this
game is in 1080p and it looks great I
have noticed that Nintendo brand
nintendo games on a nintendo console
they just look awesome this one's loaded
in 1080p which makes me look at xbox one
of them like your games are no they're
not 1080p all the time were you
officially asked your beat what are you
doing this game has so much replay value
I had to rip myself away from be like
Jeremy give it duty to the fence you
review this for them and you can go back
and rot your brain and some Nintendo
games again the game is just so much fun
to play because every mode you do there
are a lot of modes in this game there's
so much to do when you're killing time
in this game you're unlocking so I'm not
done unlocking things there's so much
music in this game oh my god I'm always
lucky music and I have not yet gotten
the thing is like you have unlocked all
the music new modes in this game include
master orders and crazy orders that's my
fun as novices I will spend hours of
master orders and crazy orders and I'm
just like if I'm fighting dudes here I'm
unlocking [ __ ] here I'll do crazy order
crazy orders you're a gambling addict
beware because it does have a gambling
vibe to it you do a match and you can do
another match and go for two matches or
you can just cash out and cash out means
you fight crazy hand then you get your
prizes or you can keep going and after
that round same thing you can cash out
now fight crazy hand get all your prizes
or keep going but if you lose you're
gonna lose some of your prizes you can
go for as long as you want to go I love
that mode so much I'm just honest to god
I'm neglectful in every other facet of
my life because I'm just plain crazy
orders a master order Super Smash
Brothers games are made to last years
until the next Super Smash Brothers game
comes out late with super smash brothers
melee my friends and I played until
brawl came out then brawl we play a lot
so we didn't anymore because there's
some mechanics in that game it just
irritates the [ __ ] out of me I'm one of
those people I will look you in the eyes
and tell you all right I like the extras
and the modes in Brawl more than melee
but for the core fighting game play I
thought melee played better than brawls
liked intend to learn from melee and
brawl put everything that works together
and now we have the Super Smash Brothers
on the Wii U in my 3ds review I pointed
out some things that I wanted to see fix
and I swear to you they are fixed for
the Wii U version I don't know if it was
planned that way or if they just went
out there and they took fan feedback
like all right well fans want this in my
3ds review I said I wanted to see bigger
stages not only do you have bigger
stages you have big stages you have
small stages you have a variety of
stages you have nostalgic stages I was
going to call them old stages but that
sounds rude like it's a negative they're
not they're nostalgic Hyrule temples
back because I love hyrule temple and on
every other Smash Brothers game I just
play hyrule temple because I just love
it that much but I noticed in this Super
Smash Brothers I'll just go down to
random select whatever comes up comes up
because the stages are so well balanced
in this game is a huge mechanic of the
game is the stages for the first time
ever I like a lot of those stages in the
Super Smash Brothers game another thing
I said I wanted to see in the 3ds
version was music selection among the
stages you know the stages have all this
music you're like all right I like that
one all right let's not play that one
let's play that one sometime this one
has it there's some great arrangements
this is one of the things I love about a
Super Smash Brothers game is the music
so I'm glad I can kind of allocate what
plays blend and unlocking characters you
do unlock characters in this game not as
much as a 3ds version 3ds version you
unlock a lot of guys but on the 3ds
version you just play just play smash
and then guys start unlocking what I
said I wanted to see was actually
unlocking guys doing special things that
unlock characters not just playing smash
until you get them this game does that
you can play a [ __ ] ton of smash and
they will eventually unlock or you can
do something just one thing that unlocks
a character and I love that they brought
that back for this game couple things if
I'm critiquing here this is a review the
smash 2 remote in this game not so crazy
about it I wasn't crazy about the 3ds
smash tour but comparatively speaking of
3ds smash tour is a lot better than the
Wii U smash tour so we use smash tour
kind of plays like this Mario Party but
not really Mario it's like Mario Party
like the gold lots of Mario Party you
know it's just so chaotic I'm like I'm
not having a lot of fun it would be a
lot more fun with friends in the rooms
you can talk [ __ ] to them while you're
playing it but it's not meant to be
played on one player for sure fact is I
don't have a lot of friends so I play
with myself it's an extra thing in the
name it's not a core mechanic of the
game it's kind of like more one of the
Mortal Kombat's had like cart combat or
something like that it was like Mario
Kart with Mortal Kombat characters but
it wasn't polished because it's not what
the game was it's a fighting game that
had an extra cart game in it this is a
super smash brothers fighting game with
this extra little Mario Party ish mode
in it it's not like it's the only extra
game mode in this game you have so many
extra motes and here so many things to
do you just like alright well if you
don't dig one you don't have to play it
to each their own is what I said and
this isn't new to this smash brother so
I'm not gonna hold it against this Smash
Brothers but color you know it's like
free-for-all no it's not it's not a
free-for-all so everyone vs. everyone
when it's against the computer if it's a
six player mash free-for-all you versus
five BOTS today guess what is five
against one
so many times I'm like trying to escape
they're all like alright we'll go after
him it's like come on fight yourself
fight each other you should be kicking
the [ __ ] out of each other not chasing a
little old me or those what they do it's
always there today I'm like that's not
fair that's not balanced eight player
matches are chaos holy God do you see
that a player magic comes up here's what
it's like that tasmat it's like looney
tunes where she's like do you see dust
and god willing you picked one of the
ones who has a counter you just spam
countering y'all yeah that's what that
is fun though in the end Super Smash
Brothers for the Wii U improved upon
everything that was in the 3ds version
it took the 3ds version it was like hey
we'll make it bigger better more music
same solid gameplay you've come to love
with Super Smash Brothers but just for
the Wii U knows this is the Super Smash
Brothers game I feel that can carry us
through the years
Mewtwo's coming out so people like mu
twos not in it in Marsh Mewtwo is coming
out this is the party game of party
games this is an absurdly addicting game
there's so much stuff to unlock you're
gonna be here forever but that good
forever kind of way not that boring
forever kind of way
in reality Super Smash Brothers for the
Wii U is awesome tacular
I'll tell you what I'd like to see I
would like to see melee mode I feel like
among the character tweaks that you can
do you can ultimately recreate any
character that was in melee and have
them fight like they did in melee I'd
like to see you mode in Smash where you
turn on melee mode so in Smash when
you're smashing the characters play like
they played in melee if they were in
melee you have your super smash brothers
melee stages you have super smash
brothers melee but it's high def it'd be
like a fun fanservice I'm not pissed
it's not in it if they want to do a
patch or an update or anything like that
and make that a reality that'd be kind
of cool brittle Super Smash Brothers for
the Wii you have you played it what did
you think about it wherever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more